[Inaudible].
What's up people.
It is November 25th,
2021 day before Thanksgiving. I'm Dave Rubin and this is the Rubin report.
Correct message. I just realized, as I looked to the side,
I looked at my camera for a second on the screen over there, I'm dressed like,
it's like, it's the summer today. This is like, I'm in,
I'm going to a cocktail party on the roof in Beverly Hills when I should be
in some sort of more festive fall thing.
But I guess I'll have to make up for that next week.
I'll do a little more of a fall outfit, some darker colors,
maybe some Browns and some oranges right now.
I look like I'm off to a Cabo or something for a very important business
meeting. Um, Hey, real quick, before we do anything else,
I want to address that two days ago, we showed you a video, uh,
that I said to people I wanted to source better and we weren't exactly sure what
was going on, but it was a video of,
of police officers assaulting somebody over violating curfew.
And I said that according to the Twitter account, it came from,
it was from California. Uh,
but if we had any more information that we would address it and I'm not above
being honest with you guys, actually, that's exactly how I want to be.
So it turns out that that video is from October in Wisconsin.
So it's just worth mentioning. Uh, but I, I,
although I had a feeling that maybe it wasn't exactly what it was, what it was,
I thought it was worth showing to you guys because the idea of people being
assaulted and attacked by police officers for violating curfew in America is
scary.
Whether it happens in October in Wisconsin or whether it happens in
November in California. So anyway, uh,
just putting that out there for a public information, uh,
and before we get to today's stories, uh, yes,
tomorrow guys is Thanksgiving.
That means that right now, as I speak,
as you watch this,
there are gangs of roofing criminals going
to other people's houses, getting into cars,
sometimes crossing state lines.
You hear me state lines to go visit friends,
family members, new acquaintances,
that they were just happened to be invited to their house,
to celebrate Thanksgiving. There are criminals amongst us here in America.
People who will literally literally eat
Turkey and stuffing and mashed potatoes
and cranberry sauce with other people in
someone else's home. They're preparing to do that. And in many cases,
traveling to those people right now,
there are people not just doing this via car.
There are people getting on airplanes to go visit,
loved ones to celebrate the holiday tomorrow.
And we're just going to sit here and let it happen. Okay.
What has happened to America? What has happened? I, I don't know.
It's just, it's scary stuff.
So I just wanted to address that up front that most of us are now Outlaws on the
run from the government,
because you're probably going to have Thanksgiving with someone that doesn't
live in your house, and this is how stupid everything has become.
Uh, but speaking of stupidity, uh, we're gonna do a couple of stories today.
And then, uh,
and then I just want to give you guys a nice Thanksgiving message and then we're
not doing a show tomorrow. We're not doing a show on Friday.
We're not doing a show over the weekend.
I want to give my guys a little time off it's it's time to be thankful.
And I hope that you're going to be with family and friends tomorrow and over the
weekend. And maybe we can all, uh,
avoid a little bit of the political madness and the current events for,
for a couple of days. Uh, so the stories we're covering today, uh,
bill de Blasio, who's probably the worst mayor in all of America.
And that's tough because, you know, we have cities like Portland, Seattle,
Los Angeles, and San Francisco. Uh,
he has COVID-19 checkpoints going up at bridges right
now. Uh, if any of you saw, I am legend,
I tweeted out the video this morning.
Remember when will Smith was trying to get his family out of New York city?
They had checkpoints at bridges in New York city did not go that well for will
Smith and family. So we're going to talk about that.
And then I'm going to show you two clips.
One from NBC news and one from ABC news,
they are super duper excited about this Biden administration.
And they are just so happy to be doing journalism about people that they
love and they can't contain their happiness and their even coordinating their
language around the happiness that they all have. It's very, very exciting. Uh,
and then two more quick stories. Uh, one this incredible,
absolutely freaking staggeringly mind-blowingly phenomenal
video out of the United Arab Emirates, where Avi Berkowitz,
who works for the Trump administration.
And it had something to do with the deals that are causing actual peace in the
middle East. Well,
now they've got Israeli fruit in the United Arab Emirates and he takes a video
at a store and they've got the flags of the countries. And it's just incredible.
And I'm guessing you haven't seen the video because although it went,
it went wild on Twitter in amongst the right wing, scary conservatives. Um,
you know,
it doesn't really fit the narrative that Trump might have done something good
for the world. So you're not going to see it on mainstream. Uh,
and then finally, governor Kate Brown. Well,
she's got a Thanksgiving video that I saw this morning,
basically telling you to invite uninvite everybody to your Thanksgiving.
And I thought it would be worth seeing to show how hysterically psychotic these
people are. And then I'll wish you guys all Thanksgiving. Uh,
but before we get to any of that guys,
this holiday season will undoubtedly be like no other.
There is no doubt about that.
Families may not have the opportunity to be physically together due to COVID-19
and the lockdown, social distancing, and financial restraints.
Despite the global events that may keep us apart.
Physically ancestry brings you closer to family past and present through your
history.
Ancestry is the family activity and gifting solution for the highly unusual
2020 holiday season. I've used ancestry.
We've been able to locate records from my family,
literally back into the early 18 hundreds.
And then I've got a genealogist in my family. Who's even gone further than that.
It's pretty incredible.
The holiday sale at ancestry is the perfect time to treat someone you love to a
gift that connects them to family and new, meaningful ways.
Find amazing prices on gifts that will let your family explore their past,
share fascinating stories and discover the places around the world.
Their ancestors called home.
An ancestry DNA test can tell you where your ancestors are from.
An ancestry is billions of records and millions of family trees.
Let you discover their unique stories.
Don't miss this special holiday pricing on truly meaningful gifts during the
holiday sale at ancestry, head to my URL at
ancestry.com/ruben, to get your ancestry gift today. That's ancestry.com/rubin.
And now back to me. Okay. So yeah, I brought it up already,
but criminals, I mean, I'm talking about far, right?
Gangs of criminals, people that right now they're traveling,
you might be traveling right now.
You might be in a car watching this on your phone, traveling clan desk,
dine to go have Turkey with your grandmother. You sick freak. Okay.
You might be one of the people doing this. Well, bill de Blasio,
the mayor of New York city, the far left lunatic, who's ruined New York city.
And all of my family members have escaped New York city already wisely,
a city that I spent most of my adult life in that I absolutely loved the
cultural. And, and in many ways, not just cultural,
the political, I think you could argue political also, not just DC,
but like the center of the world in many ways, this man has helped destroy it.
Uh,
and now he's going to have COVID checkpoints at bridges into New York city to
catch and find violators of his travel ban. Uh,
got a couple of quotes here from just the news under orders of mayor,
bill de Blasio,
New York city will have vehicle checkpoints manned by law enforcement of
officers at key bridges and crossings to strictly enforce travel
quarantine over the Thanksgiving holiday.
The city's regulations mandate that travelers either quarantined for
14 days or take a COVID 19 test to prove that they don't have the
virus by Elations of self quarantine will be enforced and ma may carry fines
of one to $2,000 according to the mayor's office. Okay,
you guys, I think we probably share a similar sentiment on just these,
these hysterically overreaching. I would argue at this point,
anti-constitutional authoritarian lockdowns that they are doing, uh,
the idea that you cannot travel freely in the United States,
that you cannot be trusted to say, if you live in New York city, I mean,
think about it this way. When they're talking about the bridges of new city.
So if you're in New York city and you want to travel out to New York city,
you're probably going to long Island, you might be going to Westchester Jersey,
Pennsylvania, Connecticut, like that's, you know, and then there's some,
obviously some States further than that,
but you're doing like the tri-state area kind of thing. And most likely,
you're going to family,
the idea that the government and this lunatic mayor thinks that you can't
make the right decisions for your family,
so that if you get in the car with your family and then go to somebody's house
and decide to have the most to celebrate actually the most
important American holiday with members of your family or friends,
and that you can't be trusted to do it responsibly or,
or whatever way you feel you should. And that,
that then gives them a right to have checkpoints on our
bridges. Like guys, if you don't see it already, I don't know what to tell you,
but this is not about COVID. At this point,
they are testing to see how far they can push you. Can we have,
what else can we have lockdowns for? What else can we have, uh, checkpoints for?
Can I see your papers? Remember, remember when seeing papers, uh, that,
that was a bad thing in, in Nazi Germany. Remember that like again,
and I say it every time,
because I know people want to misquote me and misinterpret what I say that is
not to diminish the reality of COVID 1990 9% of people,
97.5 to 99% of people get better. We know we've got these vaccines coming.
The idea that we are letting the governments run crazy with this stuff is
absolutely insane. Um, they also said there's a couple of other points here.
The New York city sheriff said that the Sheriff's office will be conducting spot
checks when out of state buses drop people off.
So if grandma got on a bus to come visit you,
she's also going to get questioned when she gets off that bus. That seems,
that seems good. Uh, Oh, and governor Cuomo, he wants,
he wanted everybody to cancel all their plans.
Then it turned out that he was going to celebrate Thanksgiving with his 89 year
old mother who he doesn't live with and he got shamed. And now he's saying,
he's just going to work all day. Yeah, work. Right. You're the governor.
You don't have anything to do. You're you're you're come on fool. Uh, and, uh,
Oh, well now actually,
maybe this has been even updated since I last looked at it. Um,
now he's saying that maybe his mother,
his 89 year old mother and his two kids will come to his place up in Albany.
So I'm actually unclear about that, but here's, here's one for you,
for everybody that, uh,
takes a picture of a well-known mayor or governor,
a mayor of a major city or a governor breaking their own rules.
If you can get a picture of it, I'll give you a 500 bucks.
So I'll do that up to say 2000 bucks. So, uh,
for people that I can find a picture,
you find me a picture of daba Newsome with other people outside of his family,
or build a Blasio outside his family or Cuomo or any of these clowns.
I'll throw in 500 bucks per picture that you take as long as it's all confirmed
and good to go and not breaking any laws,
don't break into anyone's homes or anything like that, please.
But these people are all frauds.
We know they're going to celebrate holidays in ways that they're,
that they're telling you not to celebrate them. And,
and of all years that we ever needed to, to be thankful, right.
And, and to be around family, right?
My own family's Thanksgiving is messy this year because of certain,
because of age and people not wanting to travel them and a whole bunch of stuff,
like we're all dealing with this. And if there was ever a time,
you needed to sit around the table and hash some stuff out. It's like,
now's the time to do that.
And I'm also seeing all these think pieces in the New York times and these other
places about how to, how to avoid talks at Thanksgiving.
And don't talk about politics and blah, blah, blah. And it's like, well,
you guys have made politics or religion. My family,
I write about this in my book. I mean, we grew up arguing about politics at the,
at the table, but it was always civil. And then at the end,
dessert was served and everybody was fine. We could use more of that.
We could use more face to face talks.
So we'll just leave all of our communication to Twitter. Cause that,
that seems like it will be sane. So anyway,
do what you think is right for you and your family.
And I have a feeling that everything will be okay. Uh,
but let's talk about our deeply corrupt and uh, potentially at this point,
state run media because I saw these two clips yesterday,
one's from NBC and one's for ABC.
And I think you'll find a language that the two anchors use in this
case, it's Martha Raddatz at ABC.
And it is a Andrea Mitchell at NBC. There,
there's an interesting choice of words and the way they frame these new
Biden administration picks. And I think you're going to see, well,
it goes without saying, uh,
they're treating this a little bit differently than they treated the previous
administration, but let's, let's do Andrea Mitchell first.
Let's listen to Andrea Mitchell discussing Biden's new administration
picks his captain.
Uh, they are now being told that it is not going to be political.
And Joe Biden is saying, these are people.
This is a team who's going to tell me this team will tell me what I need to know
what, not what I want to know. That is a big change.
All right. That's just one little bite there. And I guess, uh, on surface value,
if you just listen to it, it doesn't sound that bad, but if you unpack it,
those 12 or 15 words, she said,
it does sound a little worse because they're not going to be political. That is,
that is rather incredible. The president of the United States,
the incoming president of the United States is putting people in his
administration who are not political.
Although their jobs are completely political.
These are political positions chosen by a politician to
figure out the political laws that we will live under.
You see why this is silly, but these people, it's not going to be like Trump.
They're not going to tell him what he wants to hear.
They're going to tell him the truth, but orange man bad did it the other way.
And not only that, but they're not even political.
These people they're gods,
they're just benevolent public servants who live to serve and they have no
political beliefs and they're above it all in there working for Joe Biden.
It's so wonderful. And if you think that's odd now, watch ABC's Martha Raddatz.
It's about the least flashy team you could possibly get.
They are deeply experienced. Uh,
they are humble and they are life long public servants.
When I look at that group up there and let's put John Kerry aside,
because as we know, he was the democratic nominee for president once,
but they are not political. They are just career people.
They have worked together for many years. I remember Jake Sullivan at the,
at the side of Hillary Clinton when she was secretary of state all the time.
And as they say, they really do reflect America.
Oh, Raddatz, Raddatz, your beat,
Andrea Mitchell there with so much nonsense.
And so little time deeply experienced, humble,
lifelong public servants. And guess what, guys,
you're not going to believe this. They're not political.
They're not political people.
They're being chosen to do jobs that are purely political things, right?
They're not in the private sector, they're in the public sector.
They didn't earn these jobs.
They're being selected for these jobs by the guy that is the supposedly incoming
president. But these people are not political.
They're also humble and decent and good. And it's just also wonderful.
She goes on to say that Jake Sullivan,
this guy he's so good and humble and not political,
that he was always next to Hillary Clinton. When she was secretary of state,
I guess she was political at secretary of state.
The guy that was right next to her the entire time he was completely apolitical.
Anyway, you see why this is just nonsense.
This is what state run media sounds like. It really is. It is.
It's a white washing of truth.
They lie to your face in a way that kind of makes you feel good about, Oh,
the new people. Aren't going to be political and they'll be in charge.
And they're just humble public servants.
They're not like those evil mean Republicans who do everything for politics and
who are mean, and these are humble people.
They live on farms and it's like, it's,
it's such Epic nonsense. And I suspect I don't watch a lot of,
uh, Chinese TV. Uh,
but I suspect that if you were to hear about the way that
Chinese TV fawns over Chinese politicians,
I'm going to guess it's something like that.
And what you need to understand is that, and prove me wrong. Andrea Mitchell,
if you're watching Andrea Mitchell is a Democrat and Martha Raddatz proved me
wrong.
If you're watching Martha Raddatz is a Democrat and all of the people that you
get your mainstream news from are Democrats.
It just is. As I said the other day, do you think Wolf Blitzer, Jake Tapper,
Don lemon, Chris Cuomo, Brian Stelter, the entire lineup at CNN.
Are they all Democrats? Of course they are. Now people will say to me, but Dave,
what about Fox news? Yes. Fox is there first off, they're telling you that,
that does anyone Tucker Carlson hide what he is to Sean Hannity,
hide what he is by the way. Those,
those are on the opinion side of things where CNN does just a much worse job of
blending, a news and opinion. It's like a CNN is Don lemon,
limited news guy or an opinion guy. But anyway,
the point is we are going to seek so much of this sort of
thing where it'll, everything will be juxtaposed for four years.
This is assuming Biden becomes president.
And I'm still not sure that's going to happen. Uh,
but for four years we saw people who always said yes,
and they were corrupt and they only were out for themselves.
And now we have angels who live for you. The people you see,
because they are the ones who are here for you. They're not political.
They're wonderful, magical unicorn like creatures. Oh,
Lordy, Lordy people. Our work is cut out for us. All right,
let's move on to story. Number three, this is really incredible. I, I saw this.
This is, this is absolutely staggeringly, incredible. Oh.
And I should reference actually that one of the things from the previous story,
because it blends us right into this so perfectly is that she also mentions
Martha Raddatz and the previous thing she mentions, um, John Kerry right now,
John Kerry, who was secretary of state under Obama, did nothing.
John Kerry has never accomplished anything. He, he lost as president, you know,
the nominee, uh, years ago. Uh, he did that against George W. Bush,
but he's never really accomplished anything other than he married a Heinz,
right? So he's got great access to catch up. If you need up,
you go to John Kerry and also he's had a tremendous amount of Botox.
So if you need Botox advice or you need access to large quantities of
catch-up, you should talk to John Kerry. But besides that,
he's never done anything good. He's never really accomplished anything.
And as a matter of fact, there's an incredible video. Uh,
maybe we'll play it for you next week. We should have grabbed it for today.
There's an incredible video of a couple of years ago where John Kerry is going
on and on and on about middle East peace.
And it must be done with the Israelis and Palestinians first,
you can't go to these other countries first.
And literally everything he said is wrong.
Everything is he has said is proven wrong as all of these peace deals come.
And there has been no war in essence in the last four years and everything else.
I mentioned all of that because now our next story is this is Avi Berkowitz who
works for the Trump campaign and was a part of a longer Jared Christian or a
couple of other people, uh,
helping push these deals with the United Arab Emirates and with Sudan.
And we're seeing some really amazing things happen. So obvi posted this video,
this is from the United Arab Emirates and it's, it's truly staggering.
And yet I'm guessing you didn't see this on mainstream media.
Okay. Friends, you have to see that right now.
I mean the middle of the fresh fruits and vegetables market in
Dubai, the United, uh, in the rights,
see what they put in front of the store,
the flag of Israel, the flag of the UAE together, uh, from roots.
But wait until you see that
you can see,
they put Israeli product C with the flag of Israel on it.
You can buy oranges and avocado and
other stuff with the flag of Israel.
I'm just thinking about all these BDS activists who want to boycott Israel,
uh, from UVA, from United States,
and to see an out of country who is giving the answer
by bringing Israeli products with, uh, uh, with,
uh, Israeli flags, wait,
we'll see the avocado and the dates,
and to see the people that are coming in buying and it's in the front of the
store, not on the backstage, in the front of the store.
That's the answer that our country is given to all
these BDS activists around the world. Who's calling to,
we're calling to boycott Israel. This is the answer guys you want, uh,
you want to buy oranges, just come,
come to the United Arab Emirates to buy it
amazing, complete.
That's how you make peace. Guys.
You make peace by having these exchanges of commerce by trading embassies
and ambassadors and things like that.
This is completely against what John Kerry said.
It's completely against what all the experts have said over the years,
by the way, the same exact experts who are now all being imported into the Biden
administration. So I thought it was just worth showing that, I mean,
the idea that it, an Arab market,
that they wouldn't have the Israeli flag there with the Jewish star and the
whole thing that nobody's burning it down. There's no buddy attacking anything.
Nobody vandalizing anything. That's the seeds of peace.
I know this is very upsetting to Ilhan Omar and Rashida to leave, but yeah,
peace, peace can happen. People.
It actually kind of happened and it's happening right in front of our faces.
And hopefully, um, well hopefully we're not just going to throw it away, uh,
with whatever happens over the next couple of years. Um, Oh, you know,
before I get to our final story about Thanksgiving, which, uh,
which is an important one, I realized that in my,
in my ability to Blasio bit about locking down the city and the checkpoints and
everything,
I wanted to put a particularly special message out there to build a buzzy.
Because yesterday I put a very personal,
important message out there to, uh, to Gavin Newsome.
And many of you were very excited about it was it's important.
A lot of people shared it. Uh, so I do want to put a message out there to,
to build a Blasio. So here we go,
build a Blasio mayor of New York city. Well,
this message goes out to you. And I want to be very careful with my words here.
So bill de Blasio.
Go yourself.
One more time. Bill de Blasio,
go yourself.
All right. I felt good about that.
Now let's move on to Thanksgiving people because I know you're going to
celebrate it in the ultimate act of defiance. You might hug people.
You might kiss people. You might sing with people. Well, Oregon, governor,
Kate Brown, she doesn't want you doing any of that.
She wants you to sit home alone miserably, as I assume she will.
Although if you find out that she doesn't and you see her leaving her house, or,
you know, doing anything publicly on Thanksgiving, if you take a picture of it,
as long as you don't break any law, I'll give you 500 bucks for it. Well,
she posted this video on her Twitter account today.
[Inaudible] Oregon. Governor Kate Brown,
go yourself.
We're onto something here. I really do look forget Kate Brown,
forget everything else I wanted to just give you a little, uh,
Thanksgiving message,
which is that I hope that whatever you're doing that it makes you happy that it
gives you some joy. I hope you're going to eat great food and drink great wine.
I hope you're going to be around people that you love.
I hope you're going to escape politics for a moment and just enjoy yourself and
be thankful for the spectacularly wonderful freedoms that
we still have in America that are tenuous freedoms at best,
because they feel like they're being eroded right now,
but it is up to us to protect those freedoms and fight for those freedoms.
And perhaps more than anything else, just personally for me,
I want to thank you. Uh, people watching this,
every single person watching this,
you have given me an ability to do what I believe has given me
purpose and, and joy and happiness in this world.
And I love doing what I'm doing. And I think in some ways I've,
I've perhaps helped some of you figure out what you think of this mess too.
So it's a, it's an even exchange man. We're, we're good. And, uh,
I'm just so thankful for all of you and for my team here and for living in this
great country and I'm going to keep fighting for it. And I hope you will,
as well. And as I said, no show tomorrow, no show Friday, enjoy the weekend.
Have a great time. Eat lots of food, gain a couple pounds, drink, lots of booze,
whatever you want to do, you want to smoke a little something? It's all good.
This is America, baby. All right, thanks everybody. Enjoy your Thanksgiving.
And I'll see you next time.